hey guys this is Cameron with motion
science back with another super cool tip
for you for After Effects and this one
has to do with effects so let me show
you what I mean here so I've got 12
individual layers here of amoebas that
are animating in different ways and they
all look really cool but let's say the
client comes back and says listen I love
what you've done but I want this and
three other layers to actually be solid
pink well I'd like to set up an easy way
in my composition so I could easily make
all of these four layers pink at the
same time and then if I need to easily
change them to let's say green at a
later date they can all easily change to
green at the same time so if I'm gonna
make them pink the first thing I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna go to generate fill and
it's turned red so I'll go to the red
color make it let's just say there's a
nice pink okay now I want to do is I'm
going to select fill I'm gonna go to
edit copy with relative property links
and then I'm going to select the three
other amoebas that need to be pink so
let's say they've selected this one this
one and this one okay now all I do is go
to edit paste boom they're all pink
right so what's great about this is now
let's say the client comes back and say
oh you know what I need them green all I
have to do is go to my original layer
and change it to green and all of these
layers have automatically updated I'll
show you what's going on here if I
select this layer go to the fill effect
you can see that it's using all these
expressions to reference back to this
layer so whatever this fill effect does
on this layer it affects all of these
layers as well and this can be
applied to any effect and after-effects
as far as I know it can also be applied
to the properties like the transform
properties of a of a layer so let's say
we go back into this layer and I know
later on I'm gonna want to maybe adjust
the scale of all these together so I
would just select scale edit copy with
relative property links and then go back
these three other layers and paste now
if I go back to my original layer and I
go to my scale property you can see here
they're all scaling based upon this
first layer this is just a very simple
example of how you can use property
links you can expand on this quite a bit
and it's a very powerful tool inside of
After Effects it can ease your workflow
and make things much smoother and make
things much smoother and easier to work
with in your compositions so I hope you
learned something new please like
comment below let me know what you think
and until next time I'm Cameron and this
is motion science